what made you want to do this film are
you a fan of the original growing up oh
yeah yeah no way John I mean it's
Aladdin and it's Princess Jasmine yes
both my person all kind of love for the
movie love the character and then also
separate to that just you know the
opportunity to kind of humanize an
animated character as well was was
really was amazing cool was there a
particular song or sequence that you
were like really looking forward to
doing I think definitely the moments
where like Jasmine meets like the
suitors that come in and I was like
excited to see how the writers would
kind of those exchanges because I always
remember you know she always was quite
very quick and witty and kind of could
could go toe-to-toe with someone and
she's very smart so I was excited to
kind of you know give a bit of attitude
in those moments what do you imagine
happened to Prince Anders getting so you
know what there was a whole other scene
that had to do with a Canon and it was
so funny and Nasim actually like she
improved loads in that scene and it was
basically that he he had he had a cannon
covered it was clearly a cannon like
guess what it is guess what it is
and so Nasim just went on this thing and
she was like a small kitten and she was
just going through all of these it was
actually really good but I'm sure I'm
sure beyond like the DVD extra or
something
Oh perfect what was your first screen
test like were you nervous or yeah of
course always nervous first screen test
I do remember screen testing with Mina
and that's when we had a little bit more
setup there was a bit of a set put
together and you know you felt a little
bit like okay I'm in a costume and you
feel a little bit more like you can
embody the character and yeah it was it
was it was fun it really was I mean
that's the thing about guys he has a
really nice energy that kind of makes
you feel kind of chill and I think that
that helped for everyone I think in
those screen tests Jasmine's always been
like a really strong
character but I feel like she's even
more so in this film um how do you think
Disney Princesses 7 have evolved from
when the original film came out to today
I think I think there's a couple of
things number one is the idea of the
Disney Princess is it's about the
context in which that person is in you
know and I think that Disney are
focusing the focusing on the character
the person the human and like what their
journey is and I think that's the most
important thing right is that you want
to humanize the characters as much as
possible even within the context of this
fantasy world that they live in and so I
think that yeah I think that's kind of
the main thing really how do you think
Jason managed to Train Roger because
cats don't do anything you want to and
that's a tiger I think that you know
it's that loyalty thing with animals
Roger was my in my understanding I
reckon Roger was given to work when
Jasmine was born I reckon Oh No maybe
because the cat wouldn't be that okay
would then be too old let's just go
let's run with that idea probably given
when she was born and then like you know
like they have that animals and their
loyalty in their connector to humans and
I reckon he's just like just connected
yeah like the bodyguard like would let
nothing happen to her
he's your Kevin caster yes not that one
no that version